it's like the world's biggest buffet
menu and we gonna take a bite out of
everything we're talking street racers
off-road pro racing freestyle we can
take a test run with any of them or if
you asked me do them all hit which what
do you want to try first let's go my
friend
welcome to the motor nation after 30
hours the crew has left me with a lot of
wonderful memories they aren't the kind
of memories that are filled with
emergent stories you get from exploring
an open world and they're not memories
that involve goofing around with other
strangers no but the crew is lacking in
both of these aspects instead my
memories are filled with the game's
variety of vehicular activities and the
wonderfully curated tracks the
unrealistic the impossible and the
delightful
[Music]
it's surprising to see just how much the
crew to defense from the original game
there's been a noticeable shift in who
be selfs last few open all titles one
that's been moving towards a focus on
player driven progression which means
large sections of optional activities
nonlinear structures and rewards been
doing just about anything and the crew
benefits significantly from this
direction the gritty crime angle from
the original game is gone and instead
the crew 2 takes reams of pages from
forth the horizon the game centers on a
nationwide festival of Motorsports where
you are rookie are poised to become the
next big star
but while the setup is conventional and
the focus on social media fame is
obnoxious what a brings to the game is a
colorful and upbeat vibe as well as an
impressive variety of different
disciplines and positively ridiculous
arcade driving on land water and through
the air despite the game's focus on
real-world branding and the similarities
to televised motorsports the crew twos
greatest asset is its willingness to be
ridiculous races in the crew too might
involve jumping your street racing car
off skyscrapers or your power boat off
the Hoover Dam
they might include making high speed
touring cars go head-to-head through the
tight windy Hollywood Hills and making
motocross bikes take huge jumps across
shipping containers in freeways right
before you transform into a plane like
some kind of extreme sports Mecca this
is a game that will cover LA in three
feet of snow for no logical reason other
than the fact that icy roads make for
more thrilling street races abundant
nitro boosts uncomplicated drifting and
generous rubber banding also help keep
the act of driving exciting when things
are relatively tamer as a game with an
open world racers and challengers can
naturally be found when you stumble
across them at particular points on the
map however playing the crew - with
open-world exploration is your primary
means of moving from activity to
activity reveals the game's major
downfall it's too big and all the
activities and interesting locations are
too spread out it was that in mind the
crew - thankfully makes it easy to cut
your commute down via player friendly
shortcuts the game is an option to view
all hundred-and-twenty primary
activities and countless more skill
challenges in a categorized
list style view with the option not just
to set a waypoint to them but instantly
start them no matter where you are in
the world at no cost the loading times
in the crew - are impressively brief all
around so if you want to you can turn
through races and challenges
back-to-back - very quickly and
efficiently rack a progression points
earn cash
and set leaderboard positions from the
moment you start it's an option that's
both convenient and gives the impression
that the game is conscious of your time
likewise any activity can be restarted
or aborted in seconds if you're having a
bad run and there's a quick back on
track feature that can be used at any
time when you're not in an event you can
switch to any vehicle you own
immediately without penalty and without
having to go anywhere that's on top of
being able to assign a favor ground
vehicle boat and plane to your right
analog stick to allow for instantaneous
switching during free room exploration
which provides its own kind of fun
[Music]
any vehicle that's available for sale
it's also available for you to quickly
test drive on a moment's notice the
variety of different vehicular
disciplines in the crew - is downright
impressive
each of the 14 stars is tangibly unique
one another each is housed within one of
four families which are free to move
between to perpetuate your overall
progress all up the crew has street
racing drifting drag racing long
distance hyper car racing across country
Rally Raid motocross loose surface
rallycross plane aerobatic jet sprint
boating monster trucking power burning
air racing touring cars and Grand Prix
but while the execution of the crew
two's disciplines might not completely
satisfied purists of any one given style
it does a great job of making each feel
accessible fun and unique I'm usually
too intimidated by Grand Prix racing to
give it a shot in other games and I
would have never even considered the
idea of playing a power betting game
before this but the crew - encourages
you to try a little bit of everything
and it's easy to do that thanks to the
game's approachable arcade style
mechanics as well as the prospects of
seeing more beautiful and ludicrous
tracks and those tracks are certainly
another highlight of the game because
there's an inherent novelty to the
virtual tourism of the crew - you'll
likely recognize iconic structures but
there are also enough abstracted details
that contribute to each city's
atmosphere and character and like the
original game the crew - does a great
job at building a seamless and
recognizable version of America to drive
through whether it's a designated top to
bottom endurance race or a self assigned
recreation of a road trip you did a few
years back and whether you're driving
boating or flying across the crew two's
America it's a mostly beautiful journey
the game's natural environments
particularly bodies of water and the sky
look fantastic as do weather effects
like snow and rain all are enhanced the
breathtaking heights by the superb
lighting though the continuous day/night
and weather cycle can be an occasional
inconvenience during some events where
the visuals visibly falta are in dense
urban areas you likely won't notice
buildings when you're zooming past him
but any slower and you can't help but
notice how plain they are especially in
broad daylight with clear skies
character models on the other hand
always look incredibly basic no matter
the situation now the games RPG style
vehicle upgrade system returns from the
original game though it still doesn't
feel particularly meaningful you will
receive loot after every race you win in
various ages of rarity and each
corresponds to a particular vehicle pod
and had to turn
how number which contributes to your
vehicle's overall power number there is
some small benefit to the system because
all vehicles of a particular class
despite having different power levels in
their stock configuration will max out
as the same number meaning you can stick
with your favorite car all the way up to
and through the endgame but while some
parts come with unique gameplay perks
and more professional cheating options
eventually become available
I found the upgrade system pretty easy
to ignore simply equipping the one of
the biggest number was all I had to do
to stay competitive the key system as a
whole feels like it's there to act as an
additional roadblock to make sure your
progress the higher tiers and races
stays gradual and there were a few times
where I found it necessary to play a
bunch of races I had already won in
order to earn higher grade parts to give
myself a reasonable chance in later
events another obstacle is the cost of
vehicles you're required to purchase to
be able to participate in certain
disciplines buying a vehicle in order to
gain access to something advanced like
air racing or Grand Prix is expensive
and will typically empty out your
in-game wallet completely now I didn't
need to dip into the games real-world
currency equivalent to progress during
my playthrough but people who like to
keep a garage filled with lots and lots
of different cars will likely have a
tough time with in-game credits now the
crew - allows you to form a party with
three other players to explore and
participate in events together but at
the time of recording the game doesn't
offer any meaningful ways to interact
with plays outside your party despite
their visible presence in the always
online world aside from manually
inviting them into your own party by the
roster menu there is no way to formally
challenge them to a race in any capacity
Ubisoft has stated that PvP love is a
plan is a free content update in
December on top of new vehicle
disciplines and other updates but they
don't exist in the crew - as of July
2018 the crew choose large open world
feels too sparse to be engaging enough
for anything more than some wide virtual
tourism and it's easy to disparage it
because of that but that world also
provides the landscape for the game's
most memorable experiences and these can
come hard and fast if you want them to
there's always a ridiculously indulgent
twist or spectacular moment whether it
be drifting off cliffs in a snow-covered
Grand Canyon before transforming into a
boat to jet down the Colorado River or
hurtling down a mountain during a
spectacular sunset in a rally
I'm annoyed by the games like a public
interaction and meaningless Kia system
but I'll fondly recall both the tension
of flinging sprint boats back and forth
through the narrow artificial canals of
the Venetian Hotel in Las Vegas and the
easygoing satisfaction of an hour-long
hyper car race I did from New York to
San Francisco where I listened to a
podcast and just enjoyed the rolling
scenery despite its shortcomings the
crew too still displays admirable
strengths which line its player friendly
features freedom of movement and its
willingness to bend the rules in order
to make things exciting and very for an
accessible American themed
throwaway
[Music]
you